happy Halloween youtubers fake it till
you make it this is gonna be my Walking
Dead episode 3 video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet it was kind of like The Walking Dead
doing Wizard of Oz in Carroll was
Dorothy like you have this journey like
the tornado of walkers the haunted
hayride that she wanders off the patio
she starts hallucinating people as if
they were still real as they're killing
them to get into the kingdom and it's
almost like you're in the Land of Oz and
everyone is play-acting like it doesn't
seem real
she learns all about Ezekiel who he
himself is kind of like The Wizard of Oz
behind the car you know don't pay
attention to the man behind the curtain
so he levels with her so let's do top 10
and comic book Easter eggs as we go
along so number 10 Dorothy in the Land
of Oz so just in the way that they
jumped around in time last season
they're doing the same thing this season
we pick up right in the moments after we
last saw Carol in the season 6 finale as
they bring her back to the kingdom like
she was getting ready to die so they
treat her she's out for about two days
so you can guess like based on next
week's episode by the end of this
episode
they are like synched in time their
current in time with the other survivors
storyline so number 9 explaining Ezekiel
this is like the greatest thing ever
where Carol's like what the hell is
going on here in Morgan just can't quite
find the words he's just like okay you
know he's doing his own thing he's
basically trying to explain to Carol
that he might seem like a crazy person
but he's doing everything he can to keep
her alive so just please play along
until we can leave but the Ezekiel
cheveux reveal was great like the way
they wheel her into the church and you
see him sitting there on his throne the
roar of that CGT tiger it looks great it
looks way better than it did in the
trailer but you know obviously the way
they master episodes and editing is like
way more high quality for the actual
episodes than the trailers so number
seven is like my new favorite character
Jerry who is basically like he's not a
replacement for Abraham but he's like
this huge right-hand man dude who's just
ready to throw down on a moment's notice
but can't help himself from making jokes
Jerry please calm down even later he
does the doose's thing like when it
seems like Ezekiel is gonna throw down
with Carol like he totally does
care how serious the situation is but
he's like but I'll be over here if you
need me
deuces so I'll understand if you cry
foul because he totally stole that from
Abraham the deuces thing was kind of
Abraham's thing you're still kind of sad
that he died but at least deuces lives
on in Jerry so Jerry is one of my new
favorite characters for number six the
pigs wTF is up with the pigs you find
out pretty quickly but they're basically
poisoning the savior slowly as much as
they can but like they said next week is
produce week so they're giving the
lettuce so it's not like they can just
load them up on tainted meat but that's
what they're doing it was the same thing
when the wolves were trying to eat Bob's
leg like haha tainted meat got you fools
eating tainted meat won't turn you right
away but it will make you sick you will
die and then you'll turn so they are
dropping a big dirty bomb on the
Savior's number 5 though is that they're
keeping it a secret from everyone at the
kingdom not just that they're giving
them tainted meat but did they actually
have a truce at all which just sounds
like a terrible idea that's gonna blow
up in everyone's faces any time you keep
a secret that big it always gets out
eventually so the minute you learn about
this conspiracy that is the hill has
going like this Sherrod this kingdom of
Oz that he's trying to give these people
like a happy way of life there's just no
way that it's gonna last speaking of not
lasting what about all this Bend stuff
like they set him up like he's the
surrogate son of Ezekiel like Ezekiel
was really close to his father
his father died because of some decision
that Ezekiel made and they had been
close so it sounds like he kind of
adopted Ben out of guilt in a way so you
know Ben is this important person to him
he asked Morgan to take care of him they
have this nice through line through the
episode about being a realist in
adjusting your course you know that's
what he says hey Morgan I think that Ben
is in need of an adjustment and it
mirrors really nicely with what's going
on with Carole's arc but it just goes
back to what Morgan said to Ben you can
teach people the right way but they just
have to learn it on their own I'm still
trying to figure it out so that's what's
going on with Cara like she's just
figuring out her own way to but number
three was the actual Throwdown with the
Savior's Richard the person from the
kingdom versus Gavin
and the really [ __ ] Savior dude that
is definitely going to come back anytime
someone is that terrible they always
find a way to bring it back in a really
rewarding payoff so hopefully we'll get
to watch Richard just tear him apart
later too this season but Gavin is just
like the newest Dwight just a really
annoying evil character and it's gonna
be so much fun to watch him get his
brains splattered number two is Carol
and Ezekiel in the Garden of Eden like
they had that whole biblical thing going
on this is the garden it's my favorite
place
Ezekiel is the king kind of like a God
among his people
you have the apple of knowledge like you
should really try these these are
amazing
so Ezekiel explains to her his Wizard of
Oz origin story which was great I was a
zookeeper
I saved Shiva then she just treated me
like a friend thereafter I keep her on a
chain but I don't keep her she could
leave anytime she wanted there's no way
I could control her like he basically
explains that Shiva does what Shiva
wants to do so Shiva becomes this
metaphor for Carol Carol is the tiger
you know boom mind blown Carol is like
this deadly destructive force that can't
be forced to do anything you can't keep
her on a chain thus we get to you know
number one she goes off on her own
seemingly leaves has this amazing
goodbye with Morgan you're definitely in
my top three people that I ever tried to
knock out but then you know big twist
like the scene keeps going on so you're
like wait a minute what's what's going
on here in the tiger sort of comes
calling it the door with the growl in
Ezekiel gives her the Apple just letting
you know that she's going to be working
with Ezekiel even though it seems like
she's not like she's living down the
road so she'll be able to alert them
when the Savior's are coming so she is
still helping them out but she's kind of
on her own so that's what Ezekiel meant
when he said maybe you can leave and not
leave at the same time so let me know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode I feel like their conversation
in the Garden of Eden so to speak was
probably the best thing ever
where is eco just totally levels with
her like I had a little bit of theater
training and these people started
following me it's in people's nature to
follow someone they
want someone to make them feel safe so
that's what all of this theater is for
but I will totally do a trailer video
for Episode three tomorrow just talking
a little bit more about the daryl stuff
with the Savior's like we spent this
episode with the Kingdom next week is
gonna be like a Savior's episode so
we'll get to see what's going on with
Daryl we'll talk a little bit about
comic book stuff but Ezekiel like most
of the comic book stuff in this was
right off of the page
Ezekiel on the TV show seems like a
little bit younger than Ezekiel in the
comic book but it did seem like they
kind of rushed the reveal like Ezekiel
explaining how he was like The Wizard of
Oz like this is all just an act I just I
put this on to make people feel safe a
little bit faster than it happened in
the comics but it was a great episode it
was a nice you know fresh breath of
relief after that crazy intense negan
episode but we're jumping right back
into the fire next week so they're
definitely jamming their foot on the gas
like full steam ahead saviors and
Meighan so it's gonna be crazy next week
but there is a new round of the giveaway
that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video is just a $20 Amazon gift card so
I'll post that trailer video for episode
3 tomorrow well you guys wait for that
to post you can click down here from my
non-spoilery Doctor Strange review and
you can click here for my Walking Dead
episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight